one of the easiest pieces in chess to  understand their movements are the  bishops from the starting position  whites bishops occupy the squares f1 and  c1 blacks bishops occupy the squares f8  n c8 the bishops move on diagonals the  white bishop on c1 controls the diagonal  c1 to h6 as well as the diagonal c1 283  the white bishop on f1 controls the  diagonal f1 to a6 as well as the  diagonal f1 to h3 let us assume that  white moves his bishop from c1 to f4  Black's bishops similarly have the same  ability as whites  let's assume the bishop moves to the  square f5 keeping the symmetry in this  position the bishop on f1 could go all  the way to the b v square  notice that the bishops spend their  entire careers on the same colors since  Bishop b5 came with a check it would be  natural to block the check with the ship  on f5 to d7 the bishops always move only  on the diagonals  you